as you look to make your services more
reliable and easier to operate
logging becomes increasingly important
both during normal operation
and troubleshooting today i'm here to
show you what's new in google cloud
logging
and help you get started this is the
stackdoctor
[Music]
we've looked at logging errors in the
previous episode but cloud logging has
gotten a major update since then
the logs viewer is entirely new and
there are new capabilities under the
hood let's take a look
you can access the logs in your cloud
project by going to the products menu
and selecting logging under operations
this will bring you to the logs viewer
note that you can pin products in the
menu so that they're always at the top
of the list
logging is probably one of the ones i
use most
the new logs viewer has three main
sections the query builder at the top
is what you use to filter the logs in
your project to just the entries you
need
the query results at the bottom shows
you all the log entries that match your
query
the histogram view in the middle shows
you the volume of logs that match your
query
over time this is incredibly useful if
for example you're looking to understand
when a particular error started
happening
there are two primary ways to create
queries against your logs
the first one is use the menu selections
the second is to write the query
directly
let's take a look at both first you can
use the menu selection in the query
builder to select the resource
log type and log entries severity that
you'd like to include in your query
you can make your selections as granular
or as broad as you like
the query builder will then generate the
string query for you based on your
selections
your second option is to write the query
directly without using the menu
selectors
this may become easier and faster for
you once you spend some time using the
query builder
we've also published a library of
queries you can use to get started we'll
link to that below
note that this new logs viewer is still
in a preview stage this means that lots
of features are still being developed
one of these that's only available in
the classic logs viewer is the ability
to save and share queries
this is incredibly valuable when working
with teammates
you've now seen how to view and query
logs in your project but how do logs
actually get there
let's take a look under the hood the
cloud logging api
is the external endpoint that serves as
the single entry point for sending logs
to cloud logging
no matter where logs are coming from
whether it's from a logging agent
installed on compute vm
your application running in gke or app
engine or any of the google cloud
services
they're all sent to the logging api the
api
sends log entries to log router this is
the internal plumbing that determines
what happens to log entries that it
receives
the log router evaluates each entry to
determine whether it meets the filter
criteria for any exclusions
if an exclusion is applicable that entry
is discarded
that's not the case the entry is stored
in the cloud logging back-end and is
then available to be query through the
logs viewer or for log-based metrics
the log router also evaluates each entry
that it receives
to determine whether it should be
exported to a downstream destination
you can configure exports to cloud
storage for archiving bigquery for
analytics
or pub stuff to send logs to third-party
or event processing systems
note that the exclusion and export
evaluations happen in parallel on the
same log entry
that means you can both export log
entries and exclude them
this can often be used to great effect
to save costs
thanks for joining me today we looked at
the new logs viewer and learn how to
build log queries
we also took a look under the hood and
learned about how the log router works
to allow you to precisely control which
logs are stored
discarded or exported that's it for this
episode come back soon for more
this is the stack doctor stay healthy
out there
[Music]